so I wasn't planning on making this
video but the other day I was showing
with my mom and just like any typical
Jewish Russian mom all she could focus
on was feeding me so she brought me hurl
ideas which is a traditional Russian
dish it's just meat engulfed in its own
fat she loves it I don't know why I hate
it this is what happens I'm not happy no
no no means no hey mom no no I'm not
chew Eric you know what you should let
your friends in the office Drive because
I know that everybody's gonna like it
you peanuts oh you think it was annoying
you okay you want to make a bet yeah
what are we betting
that if you be like if you eat it oh
they like it okay and if they don't like
it even if they don't make it don't eat
it don't you what that you like it no if
they don't like it I never have to eat
this ever again it's fine agreed
oh my god oh my god hi about their lunch
excuse me hi sorry to bother you I'm
Eric's mom and we make a little bet with
Eric I brought a marriage
are you serious you're seriously
bringing your mom into this is this a
big place is too much this is like this
is a good-size fight to Eric's family
[Music]
thank you so much a chill night
what do you think literally it just
tastes like chicken and jello yeah you
like it tastes like chicken and jello we
eat it with horseradish and bread but
can they put the little horse sashimi I
honestly think that would help
yes okay let me get how much is gone
what do you really think buddy I need to
get out here this is made out of chicken
fat like I don't think this is real
jello that you get in the store I don't
taste the strawberry the chair
texturally I thought I was about to die
[Music]
yeah I get it
horseradish definitely this afternoon is
gone from zero to a hundred oh this is
typical Russian shot glass so the bet is
that if you like it Eric is gonna eat
the whole thing
oh boy I love it yeah this is really
good I love it now you have these so did
you guys like it
[Music]
[Music]
meat meat meat meat
[Music]
why is there walking there
[Music]
I'm time know I'm waiting your food's
delicious your son's business